what do you think about the long running
saga of israel and palestine will we
ever see peace in that part of the
middle east
well since i'm an optimist about human
um
look i i mean i have many many thoughts
about i'm a very very strong supporter
of israel uh
and uh and i also feel
really for the plight of the
palestinians i think that they're
you know this is uh
this is a a clash of legitimate
narratives that is impossible to exactly
split the difference of
however
um
i know that israel has made peace with
egypt has made peace with jordan has
made peace now with other arab nations
i don't believe that israel is unwilling
to make peace
and so i think
that as difficult as it will be
for the palestinians to come to grips
with the fact that the jewish state is
not leaving and is legitimately here as
opposed to we can't get rid of it now
but we will get rid of it one day
um
if that
comes to be and i believe that it will i
think not only that there would be peace
but i think that those two peoples
together could probably do remarkable
things in the world
do you think the source
of it is politics
is it religious ideas
and
to flip it what is the way out
is it
geopolitics
is it uh
you know interfaith
discourse and collaboration or
is it simply the human
um like love so i think that i i'm not
sure that i could give one answer to
that but i will give a piece of an
answer
why did the abraham accords happen
the main reason that they happened was
because economics overrode ideology
and i actually am hopeful that that's in
the end what will happen
that people will say you know what we
could have such a better life
if we put aside
the ideological animosities
and just
created this different kind of middle
east together um i went to uh dubai
to watch the world chess championship
because i really wanted to see magnus
carlson play i thought you're alive when
when you have such a remarkable world
champion go see him play so i actually
took myself to dubai that's amazing at
for the last couple of games and i
watched i and
so i wasn't so much i i mean it's not
that i'm uninterested in dubai but i
really i went there for the chess thing
the expo was also one at the same time
and i saw here's this amazing place i
came back this guy i know who lived in
dubai for several years and works in the
middle east said to me what did you
think of it and i said you know as
nice as dubai it was like very you know
very polished very sophisticated very
clean very
no crime and so on but it was like you
know kind of like las vegas in the
middle east without the gambling or
something like that he said you know
and he totally changed my perspective in
a couple sentences he said i know it
seems like that when you come from los
angeles
he said but fly there from yemen or from
riyadh
and it is a miracle and i thought oh my
god you're right
it's like what human beings can do if
they just put aside
their ideological shackles is remarkable
and i'm hopeful that one day that'll
happen economics allows for a higher
quality of life you no longer it's the
playground analogy you've you said
earlier
if there's more resources to play with
right
unfortunately us humans are more willing
to play with others yeah and maybe that
is the solution and maybe i mean for me
from a technology perspective
innovation
engineering
helps make everybody's life better and
over over that
once people's lives become better they
start to be
um
have more time to be empathetic and here
and they have more to lose
when you have more to lose it actually
makes you i think
um countries are less willing to go to
war when they have more to lose and p
and and families want peace when they
have when when it's good at home so i
think there's an element of that as well
and some of it again taking us back to
the other aspect of our conversation is
how we're conducting ourselves in
conversation online and so on because i
think actually
i'm a big fan of the idea of social
media
that is a way for us to connect
together i think there's a lot of
really strong ideas how to do that well
and clearly the initial attempts that
kind of just
open it up wide some of the lesser
aspects of human nature can take over
uh when combined with different forces
like advertisements and virality and all
those kinds of things but overall
i love the honesty of the mess of it
being presented before us on social
media i i it's part of me
maybe because i don't participate it
like if somebody is being mean to me or
being aggressive and these kinds of
things i enjoy it because it's it's
human nature right but i enjoy it
because i don't respond i think if i
responded i would get pulled into this
human nature and then it's not fun but i
i love the emote like i'll i'll talk to
people in fact i still visit clubhouse i
don't know if you know what that is sure
all right that's right actually when i
uh that's how we first met well yeah
well i was such a fan boy i actually
when i first heard you and uh i was like
i can't believe i could
talk to david
but uh the israel-palestine
um topic was something that was very
deeply in a heated way
uh
discussed on clubhouse race relations is
a thing that was really heatedly
discussed and i now go to clubhouse to
practice russian and there in russian
the heated discussion
is on basically any topic
as meaningless or meaningful as you want
in the heat of it
just people just screaming and and then
calming down and going through the full
process and that that too is beautiful
because that emotion is there and if it
is allowed to have a voice i think
ultimately it's
it leads to healing um so that that felt
really healthy if you learn how to do
that at scale
social media i i wish that it were not
as algorithmically biased towards
conflict um i don't think that that's
healthy but i do
i i think it brings a lot of blessings
into people's lives if they use it
wisely you know it can like anything
else it can be
awful um but
but it can't i
i've connected to all sorts of people
that i never would have known
and that's been wonderful
you